هجوم صاروخي اوكرانيا على شبه جزيره القرم
مساء الاثنين مدافعها بالسلطات المحليه
الى اصدار تحذير للسكان
تصدت قواتنا لهجوم صاروخي واسقطت الدفاعات
الجويه صاروخا قرب قاعده بلبكه الجويه
السلطات الاوكرانيه اعلنت من جهتها يوم
الاثنين عن تعرض ميناء اوديسا لقصف جوي
روسي خلف سته قتلى والحق اضرارا جسيمه
بالبنيه التحتيه للميناء وبالمباني
المحيطه من جانب اخر وجع الرئيس فلودي
رساله الى الاوكرانيين حملت اخبارا جيده
على حد تعبيره
الدفعه الاولى من دبابات ابرامس الامريكيه
وصلت الى اوكرانيا ونحن بصدد تجهيزها
لتعزيز عملياتنا ضد المحتلين وسنواصل
العمل للحصول على جميع القدرات العسكريه
الضروريه
الاعلان عن وصول الدبابات تزامن مع
استعدادات الجيش الاوكراني لتعزيز مواقعه
العسكريه قبل حلول موسم البرد
الولايات المتحده وعدت بتسليم اوكرانيا 31
دبابه من طراز ابرمس مزوده بذخائر تحتوي
على اليورانيوم المنظم ذخائر مضاده للدروع
لكنها تثير جدلا بسبب مخاطرها السامه على
الجنود والسكان